el presente turco recep tayyp erdogán ha
explicado hoy mismo que turquía atacará
ha dicho directamente el presidente
turco a las milicias de la siep en el
norte de siria se refiere a unas
milicias vinculadas al partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán una guerrilla
acuerdo turca que lleva en guerra contra
el estado turco desde la década de los
ochenta turquía durante esta guerra
siria que empezó en 2002 en 2011 y ha
atacado en tres ocasiones a estas
milicias y quiere hacerlo otra vez se
entra centrándose sobre todo ha dicho el
presión de turco en dos ciudades en la
región fronteriza entre siria y turquía
dentro de sí eso si se trata de man bis
y tail rifat de conquistar estas dos
ciudades turquía quiere unir las partes
que ya conquistó en el norte de siria de
estas milicias unirlas para poder crear
un corredor para poder hacer el
siguiente paso que quiere turquía que es
mandar ahí a varios millones de los
refugiados con la misma temen turquía y
esto lo hacer dogan porque las
elecciones turcas se acercan queda algo
más de un año sin embargo podrían ser
adelantadas y el presente turco vive en
un momento de popularidad muy bajo el
más base o el más bajo desde que es
líder de turquía
gran mayoría de las encuestas aseguran
que erdogán perdería estas elecciones si
erdogán quiere así calentar en una
medida preelectoral según los mayores
expertos cómo sería atacar primero siga
y después empezará una campaña de
repatriación de los refugiados y
escribirá en turquía erdogán también
hablado hoy sobre la posible adhesión de
phil de finlandia y suecia la otan ha
dicho erdogán que de momento turquía no
apoyo no va a levantar el veto porque no
ha recibido respuesta a sus
reclamaciones por lo tanto el veto a
estos dos países para entrar a la otan
sigue en pie